this is the gazprom nift installation in
ghanti mancilsk from installations like
these in siberia and across russia crude
oil diesel and petrol are pumped to
customers
taken together every day nearly eight
million barrels of crude and refined
products are exported
two-thirds of them end up in europe but
now russia's war against ukraine has
changed everything today we are
addressing our dependency on russian oil
and let's be clear
it will not be easy
because some member states are strongly
dependent on russian oil but we simply
have to do it
so today we will propose
to ban all russian oil from europe
this will be
this will be a complete import ban on
all russian oil seaborn and pipeline
crude and refined
but in order for this to happen it will
need the support of all eu member states
some are highly dependent on russian oil
and are strongly resistant to all out
embargoes the hungarians say what
matters most to them is protecting their
economy and people
war is going on and as a consequence
prices are rising in the whole of europe
there are signs of a serious crisis of
energy and the european economies are
facing miseries and we are not yet out
of the age of epidemics on april 3rd
people made a clear decision but they
expect the leaders of a country to
defend them and hungary from these
dangers
the new sanctions proposed in strasbourg
will also target several large russian
banks and other financial institutions
we finally d swift spare bank
spare bank is one of the is the largest
russian bank it holds around about 37
percent of the whole banking sector
and we will also be swift to other major
banks in russia
by that
we hit banks that are systemically
critical to the russian financial system
and putin's ability to wage destruction
the notable absentee from all this is
russian natural gas
in a sense it's the elephant in the
european living room too big to be
ignored but also too big unilaterally to
be done away with without seriously
damaging economies across this continent
and that's the problem facing eu leaders
they want to act fast against russia but
they're stuck with the reality of
decisions that governments across europe
made over decades
when they thought that it was in their
best interest to make deals with
president putin
dominic kane al jazeera berlin